Guten Tag, ich heiße Mustafa Cilic. Ich bin hier auf der Station als Assistenz, als Tätich
und würde gerne Ihnen mit das Anamnese-Gespräch durchführen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Klar, Hauptsache irgendjemand guckt mich an.
Okay, bitte geben Sie mir Bescheid oder fragen Sie nach, wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen.
Ja, gut, dann mache ich.
Ja, und der war kurz zum Ablauf. Ich werde Ihnen so erst ein paar persönliche Fragen stellen.
Persönliche Fragen?
Ja, und danach werden wir über Ihre aktuelle Beschwerden sprechen.
Ah, ja, okay.
Nicht sehr viele Personen, ja, nur Name und so weiter.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Udo Schlüter.
Udo Schlüter.
Schlüter, ja. Könnten Sie bitte Ihr Vornamen machen, stabilieren?
Ja, der Vorname ist ganz kurz U-D-O.
Ja, U wie Ulrich, ja, richtig.
U wie Ulrich, ja.
Und der Familienname, S-C-H-L-U-U-U-T-E-R, Schlüter.
Okay, ja.
Und wie alt sind Sie und wann sind Sie geboren?
Ich bin am 6.07., 76 geboren.
Ich werde also in diesem Sommer 47.
47, ja, okay.
Okay, ja, wie groß sind Sie?
Ich war mal 1,80.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das immer noch stimmt, aber ich denke ja.
Ja, okay.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ja, ich wiege, ja, so rund 86, 87 Kilo.
Ja, okay.
Okay, ja.
Wer ist die Hausarzt?
Oh, das ist Dr. Möller.
Aber ich gehe da so gerne hin.
Okay.
Sind Sie gesetzlich oder privatversichert?
Ich bin gesetzlich versichert.
Okay, ja, wir haben schon geschafft.
Ja, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ja, wissen Sie, ich habe solche heftigen Bauchschmerzen.
Und die werden irgendwie gar nicht besser.
Und das hat langsam angefangen.
Und jetzt wird es aber immer schlimmer.
Und das geht jetzt eigentlich schon,
lang eigentlich, schon Monate lang.
Okay.
Ja, ich fühle mich eigentlich ein bisschen schlecht.
Und dann habe ich gedacht, mit meinem Hausarzt habe ich nicht so ein gutes Verhältnis.
Und dann habe ich gedacht, dann komme ich lieber mal direkt hier zu Ihnen.
Okay, ja, Sie machen gut.
Und können Sie mir zeigen, wo die Schmerzen sind?
Oder können Sie mir beschreiben, wo die Schmerzen sind?
Na ja, also so im Bauch, vielleicht so um den Bauchnabel rum.
Vielleicht ein bisschen höher, so im oberen Bauch.
Da tut es heftig weh.
Okay.
Sie drehen, wie sich Schmerzen in andere Körperregionen aus?
Na ja, so runter rum tut das halt alles manchmal weh.
Manchmal habe ich auch ganz starke Blähungen.
Manchmal muss ich auch doll auf die Toilette gehen.
Und ich habe mich auch schon mal übergeben.
Und dann tut mir natürlich der ganze Bauch weh.
Okay, richtig.
Die Schmerzen sind langsam angefangen, richtig?
Das hat langsam angefangen, ja.
Und wird aber schlechter, so über Tag geht es dann mal wieder besser.
Und dann ist es wieder ein bisschen schlechter.
Also es ist nicht so, dass ich jeden Tag die gleichen Schmerzen habe.
Okay, bei Stär.
Wenn vor mich, okay.
Können Sie mir den Charakter von Schmerzen beschreiben?
Ich meine, sind die Schmerzen eher dumpf, stehend oder krampfer?
Würde die eher so, ja, so wie kräftiger Druck.
So fühlt sich das an, ja.
Okay, sind die meisten dauerhafter oder treten Sie hin und wieder auf?
Ja, also die meisten sind Sie da, aber nicht so schlimm.
Und dann werden Sie mal schlechter und dann wieder besser.
Okay.
Ja Herr Schulütte, stellen Sie sich eine Skala vor.
Das war unsere Schmerzskala.
Und bei der Schmerzskala gibt es verschiedene Niveau.
Von 1 bis 10.
Wie stark sind Ihre Schmerzen bei Ihnen auf dieser Skala?
1 entspricht der leichten Schmerzen.
Und 10 entspricht der starken, reheftigen Schmerzen.
Ja, ich kann das schon aushalten, aber ich würde sagen,
so in der Mitte bei 5 sind die Schmerzen.
Okay, gibt es bestimmte Auslöser für die Schmerzen?
Haben Sie bemerkt das?
Ja, also kann das eigentlich nicht so genau sagen.
Manchmal, wenn ich abends ein Schluck getrunken habe,
dann habe ich das Gefühl, dass es schlechter wird.
Manchmal ist es bei der Arbeit, ich habe schwere körperliche Arbeit.
Ich denke, jetzt geht es aber nicht mehr so gut.
Aber ich kann nicht so genau sagen, was die Schmerzen machen.
Okay, nächste Frage ist wie ähnlich, aber ich sollte fragen,
gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen verhindert oder erschwingen?
Zum Beispiel Essen, Belastung oder Bewegung?
Wenn ich mich ins Bett lege abends, dann wird es eigentlich so ein bisschen besser,
habe ich den Eindruck.
Abends.
Sie mein Zeit.
Okay.
Haben Sie irgendeine Tresche Medikamente dagegen eingenommen?
Nein, ich nehme nicht gerne Medikamente.
Ich trink aber wohl mal abends Schnaps.
Das hilft ja eigentlich auch, wenn man Bauchschmerzen hat.
Schnapsi, ja, okay.
Im Laufe der Zeit, ich meine,
abends schmerzt und im Laufe der Zeit,
sei es schlimmer oder besser?
Ja, klar.
Am Anfang habe ich das gemerkt,
hat das mal so ein bisschen gezwickt, aber jetzt ist das schon mehr geworden.
Okay.
Und wissen Sie, was mir aufgefallen ist?
Ja.
Ich kann eigentlich nicht mehr so gut arbeiten,
weil meine Arbeit, das strengt mich viel mehr an.
Und beim Treppensteigen, da habe ich mit einmal Schwierigkeiten,
dass ich so pusten muss.
Okay.
Bei dem Treppensteigen,
haben Sie Luftnot oder fühlen Sie sich müde?
Ja, also ich habe eigentlich das Gefühl,
dass ich stehen bleiben muss, weil ich keine Luft mehr kenne.
Ja.
Sie müssen ein Pause machen.
Okay.
Das ist das nicht gut, das ist gut, nein.
Ja, haben Sie Zwieberwürdigkeit oder Erbrechen, Herr Schütter?
Ja, also schlecht ist mir tatsächlich ja.
Schlecht ist mir und ich musste mich auch einmal übergeben,
das war irgendwie bei der Arbeit, da habe ich mich angestrengt
und da musste ich mich übergeben.
Aber schlecht ist mir wirklich ziemlich oft.
Okay.
Haben Sie Durchfall oder Verstopfung?
Ich würde sagen eher ein bisschen Durchfall.
Wie sieht der Stuhl aus?
Das ist wichtig für uns.
Eigentlich normal, so wie das, was man gegessen hat.
Also, ja, je nachdem.
Okay, ja.
Das ist nicht besonders, Sie meinen.
Nein, keine besondere.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen, Frau Schütter?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Okay.
Sie fühlen sich schlapp, ja, eigentlich.
Ich fühle mich schlapp, ja, genau.
Und manchmal habe ich auch so das Gefühl,
dass ich mir nichts merken kann,
dass ich, so wenn mir mein Vorarbeiter irgendeinfach sagt,
dass ich dann mir das gar nicht merken kann.
Und da muss ich nochmal nachfragen und so.
Also, ja.
Ich fühle mich eigentlich so insgesamt nicht belastbar.
Haben Sie eng gefehlt, Herr Schütter?
Haben Sie eng gefehlt?
Eng gefehlt, meine ich.
Eigentlich nur, wenn ich die Treppe laufe,
merke ich, dass ich außer Buste bin.
Okay.
Und wie ist Ihre Appetit?
Wenn mir so schlecht ist, habe ich nicht so viel Appetit.
Mh, schlecht.
Dann mag ich eher etwas trinken als etwas essen, ja.
In der letzten sechs Monaten, haben Sie ab oder zugenommen?
Ich habe zugenommen, ja, ich habe zugenommen.
Und es habe ich auch erledigt, meine Hosen knifen alle.
Also, mein Bauch ist dekar geworden.
Ja, okay.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Atmen?
Ja, außer beim Treppensteigen nicht.
Okay.
War Ihnen schwindelig oder schwarz vor Augen?
Nö, das ist eigentlich nicht.
Haben Sie Ihr Bewusstsein erledigt?
Ne, so viel habe ich ja noch auch wieder nicht getrunken.
Das ist gut.
Haben Sie Herzrasen oder Herzschlag?
Ja, also, wenn es mir so schlecht geht und wenn ich auch,
ja, wenn ich so merke, dass ich nicht gut drauf bin,
dann habe ich manchmal das Gefühl, dass das Herz schneller kloppt, ja.
Ja, okay.
Leiden Sie an irgendwelche chronischen Erkrankungen?
Ich meine Schildduruse, Störungen oder Zuckerkrankheit oder Blutochdruck?
Ja, also, mein Arzt hat mich mal ermahnt,
ich habe gesagt, mit der Leber ist das nicht in Ordnung.
Ich soll weniger trinken, deswegen gehe ich da auch nicht mehr hin.
Würden Sie schon einmal operieren?
Ja, ich habe mir mal den Unterschenkel gebrochen
und das war ein bisschen kompliziert und das musste operiert werden.
Das ist aber schon lange her.
Zum Beispiel vor 40 Jahren? Nein.
Ne, ne, ne, so lange?
Vor 15 Jahren ungefähr.
Gab es Komplikation oder Problem bei der Operation?
Nein.
Das ist gut.
Das hat zum Glück auch alles wieder, also jetzt ist alles wieder gut geheilt, ja.
Sind Sie vollständig gegen?
Nein, ich glaube, Corona habe ich mich auch impfen lassen,
aber sonst, ich glaube schon, dass ich alle Impfungen habe,
weiß ich aber nicht so genau.
Okay.
Waren Sie in der letzten Zeit im Ausland?
Nein, nein, nein, ich bin immer zu Hause.
Okay. Herr Schüter, Sie haben gesagt,
vielleicht es gab ein Problem, lieber,
aber nehmen Sie ganz wäschere Medikamente regelmäßig
oder gelegentlich ein?
Ja, wenn ich mal dicken Kopf habe, wenn ich Kopfschmerzen habe,
dann nehme ich mal Aspirin, ne?
Ja. Aber sonst?
Ja, wenn ich mal ein bisschen Alkohol getrunken habe,
oder so, dann erinnere ich mich auch.
Erinnern Sie sich daran, welche Dosierung Aspirin ist?
Was steht denn da drauf auf der Packung?
Ich glaube, da steht 500 drauf, kann es sein?
Okay.
Da nehme ich dann eine und wenn es nicht besser wird,
nehme ich irgendwann noch eine, aber mehr dann eigentlich nicht.
Okay, sind Sie allergisch gegen etwas?
Nein. Ich glaube, ich kann alles vertragen.
Okay.
Haben Sie Unverträglichkeit?
Ist das nicht das Gleiche wie Allergie?
Nein, also ich wüsste nicht.
Ja, nach meiner Meinung, es ist Gleiche, aber ich soll fragen.
Okay.
Wunderbar, ja.
Ja, diese Frage ist sehr wichtig für mich.
Rufen Sie?
Ne, Herr Schulter.
Ja, natürlich rauchig, ja. Was meinen Sie? Ja, klar rauchig.
Wie oft und seit wann rauchen Sie?
Ach, ich habe gar nicht so früh angefangen, Mitte 20 habe ich angefangen,
ich glaube, als ich so richtig angefangen habe zu arbeiten.
Und ja, so anderthalb Päckchen rauchig am Tag, 30 Flucken rauchig am Tag, ja.
Ja, 30 Zigarette täglich, ja, Sie meinen, okay.
Und ungefähr 20 Jahren, ja.
Ja.
Und Alkohol? Ja, trinken Sie Alkohol, ja, Sie trinken Alkohol, ich weiß das.
Ja, ja.
Wie viel Alkohol?
Auf dem Baubau.
Ja, wie viel Alkohol trinken Sie?
Da trinke man auch schon mal ein Bier, tagsüber und so.
Und ja, abends trinke ich dann auch noch so ein paar Flaschen vorm Einschlafen.
Und meistens auch noch so 2, 3 Schnäppse dazu, ja.
Einschläfe jede Abend und 2, 3?
Nein, also schon ein paar mehr Bier am Abend, ne.
Ja, vielleicht so 2, 3 Flaschen tagsüber, auch nochmal so 2, 3.
Und dann noch so ein bisschen Schnaps am Abend, ne.
Okay, okay, ja.
Ich muss diese Informationen notizieren, deswegen haben wir manchmal Augenkontakt.
Verloren, ja, ich glaube ich nicht.
Okay, ja.
Und Leidenfamilienmitglieder an chronischen Erkrankungen?
Ja, ich weiß, dass meine Mutter ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck hat.
Und das hat, glaube ich, auch Diabetes.
Und mein Vater, der ist gestorben, der hatte so ein Blut im Kopf, ne.
Der war Dement, ne.
Und der hatte aber auch dann irgendwas an der Leber.
Und da dran ist er wohl gestorben.
Ein lieber Problem, aber Sie wissen nicht, ja?
Das genau weiß ich nicht.
Okay.
Gibt es Fälle von Klebs in Ihrer Familie?
Wofiel ich weiß, nicht, dass da jemand Krebs hatte, wüsste ich nicht, ne.
Oder Alpkrankheit, Sie wissen auch nicht, ne.
Ne.
Alpkrankheit, okay.
Ja, was machen Sie, Belofi?
Ja, ich arbeite im Straßenbau.
Ja, okay, sind Sie da heiratet?
Ich bin geschickt.
Ja, haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, wir haben zwei Kinder, aber die sind bei meiner Frau.
Okay.
Leisen Sie unter Stress, was meinen Sie?
Ja, das ist natürlich nicht so einfach.
Also einmal ist die Arbeit anstrengend und dann das Allein-Design
ist natürlich auch nicht so toll jeden Abend.
Alleine zu Hause, da trinkt man dann auch schon mal ein Bier
und schnappst zu viel, ne.
Okay.
Und haben Sie Haustier?
Haustier, das habe ich nicht auch noch.
Nein, das habe ich nicht.
Das könnte ich ja gar nicht versorgen.
Dreidungssieh regelmäßig Sport?
Ja, meine Arbeit ist eigentlich schon anstrengend genug.
Da mache ich keinen Sport mehr.
Okay.
Ich möchte eine kurze Zusammenpassung machen,
um mögliche Fehler zu vermeiden.
Ja, okay.
Okay, Frau Schüter.
Herr Schüter, Sie sind 42 Jahre alt, richtig?
Bald 47, 46 im Augenblick.
Ja, 64.
Ich habe immer ein Problem mit Nummern,
deswegen habe ich mich nicht verabredet.
Also ich bin geboren am 6.07.1976.
Das heißt, bis zur Jahrtausendwende war es 24 plus 23
von diesem Jahr sind zusammen 46 plus, ja.
Vielen Dank für Ihre Bemühungen, für mich.
Okay.
Ich habe noch eine Frage,
die ich jetzt noch nicht auf dem Internet habe.
Ich möchte mal wir uns sehr reden lassen.
Ja, vielen Dank für Ihre Bemühungen, für mich.
Okay.
Okay, ja, Sie haben heftige Bauchschmerzen.
Ja.
Seit Monaten, aber jetzt ist es in Mosfet,
er wird es schlimmer.
Und unnahme-herum haben Sie Schmerzen.
wäre ich, ja, okay und das wäre für mich, ja und beim Treppensteigen
müssten sie immer ein Pause machen, ja, das ist richtig. Ja, das habe ich jetzt
gemerkt, dass ich da nicht gut Luft kriege, wenn ich mich stark anstrengen.
Ja, das war es, okay. Ja, wir haben, ich habe, ja, okay, sie haben keine Probleme mit dem Tool, okay, ja.
Ich denke, ich habe alle wichtige Fragen gestellt. Möchten Sie etwas hinzuficken, Herr Schützer?
Nee, möchte ich das natürlich nur gerne wissen, wie man diese Bauchschmerzen wieder los wird,
dass man dagegen machen kann, ob Sie mir vielleicht Tabletten geben können, damit ich dann wieder fit werde, ja.
Ja, ich erkläre Ihnen, ich erkläre Ihnen jetzt, was ich machen soll.
So erst Sie müssen bei uns hier bleiben für weitere Untersuchungen und...
Aber dann kann ich wieder nach Hause, ne?
Ja, natürlich, aber es kann dauert ein bisschen, ein paar Stunden.
Ich werde Sie Schritt für Schritt informieren.
Es machen Sie sich keine Sorge.
Und so erst ich kontrolliere Ihre Herzfrequenz und Atemfrequenz und Körpertemperatur.
Und, ja, das war das, ja, ich kontrolliere etwas, aber ich... ja, das geht etwas, ja, okay.
Und dann ich höre Ihre Herz, Ihr Herz und lüngen ab.
Dann ich untersuche Ihren Bauch, so als körperlich, dann mit Ultraschall.
Okay.
Und ich nehme Blut ab und wir brachen, ja, wir brachen Urin für Urinstatus.
Ja, das Kirchen, ja.
Ja, und Sie wissen, dass dieser ein Prozess, Diagnos, Diagnos für eine Krankheit ist ein Prozess.
Deswegen, es kann dauert ein paar Stunden.
Ja, dann warte ich halt so lange, ja.
Ich kann da zwischendurch mal eine Rauchen gehen, ne?
Ja.
Soweit Ihre Diagnose kann ich nicht viel sagen, weil nachdem diese Laborergebnisse und Untersuchungen werde ich Ihnen informieren, ja, darüber.
Ja, alles klar.
Gut.
Warum verlegen andere Fragen?
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Er glaubt ja, gegen Corona ist er geimpft und sonst ist er sich nicht so ganz sicher.
Wie viele Kissen, wenn Sie Kissen zum Schlafen?
Eins, ich habe einen Kissen zum Schlafen, ja.
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass Ihre Beine geschwollen sind?
Zwei Beine.
Ja, nein, habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Sind Sie wegen der Bauchschmerzen bei einem anderen Arzt gewesen?
Ich war vor langer Zeit bei meinem Hausarzt.
Der hat festgestellt, dass mit der Leber irgendwas nicht gut ist, dass die Leberwerte nicht gut sind und hat mir gesagt, ich soll weniger trinken.
Deswegen gehe ich da nicht mehr hin.
Haben Sie die Bauchschmerzen nach dem Essen für Schlechtes?
Nein, eigentlich habe ich da keinen Zusammenhang bemerkt.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie seit einem Monat diese Beschwerden haben.
Ich würde gerne wissen, seit drei Monaten.
Seit drei Monaten?
Ich habe nicht beschwerden, ob ich ein Jahr, zwei Jahre oder so.
Nein, solche Schmerzen hatte ich noch nie.
Sie haben vor Erkrankungen nur Leberprobleme, andere Erkrankungen.
Was ist der Fall?
Er meint, er wäre fit.
Die Bauchschmerzen wurden bei Ihnen durchgeführt.
Das weiß ich nicht.
Der Arzt hat gesagt, mit der Leber, Ihre Leberwerte sind zu hoch.
Trinken Sie mal ein bisschen weniger Alkohol.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, hat er nicht.
Wie viele Jahre trinken Sie Alkohol?
20 Jahre?
Genau so lange wie ich rauche.
Sie haben mit 20 Jahren angefangen oder?
Nein, seit 20 Jahren.
Wie sieht Ihre Wasserwasser aus?
Das sieht nicht genau hin.
Unaufhändig, er kennt das nicht anders.
Sie haben gesagt, ob wir Bauchschmerzen jeden Tag sind.
Wie viele Minuten oder Stunden dauert es?
Nicht auch die Uhr. Mal ist es schlechter, mal ist es besser.
Aber in letzter Zeit dauert es lange.
Hallo, ich würde ein Freigestellern.
Haben Sie Wasseransammlung im Bauchbereich bemerkt?
Das hat er so nicht gesagt.
Aber er hat gesagt, er hat zugenommen.
Und er hat gesagt, die Hosen passen ihm nicht mehr.
Ja.
Insofern, ist sie natürlich auf der richtigen Spur.
Bei der Untersuchung werde mir verstehen das.
Ich habe es nicht mehr gesagt.
Okay.
Wollen Sie loslegen?
Oder gibt es noch andere Fragen?
Sie haben sich erinnern,
dass Sie sich Hepatitis A oder B-Labor-Werte machen.
Das wüsste ich.
Ich glaube, das habe ich nie gehabt.
Ich habe es gesehen.
Es gibt andere Schlesferker.
Ich habe es auch gesehen.
Was gibt es dann?
Es gibt andere Schlesferker.
Nein.
Ich muss mich fragen.
Natürlich, Sie haben es vergessen.
Danke schön. Können wir als erstes beginnen, Stefan?
Ja, ich glaube, ja.
Gut.
Guten Tag, Herr Frau Berat. Wie geht es Ihnen?
Ja, gut. Erzählen Sie, Sie haben einen neuen Patienten gesehen?
Ja, ja, ich habe einen neuen Patienten, darf ich vorstellen?
Ja, erzählen Sie, wann sind Sie denn gesehen?
Ja, ich habe einen neuen Patienten, der Udo Schrüttel heißt.
Und er ist 46 Jahre alt und er ist Bauarbeiter.
Und er hat schwierige Bauchschmerzen auf eines Zerf bei fünf.
Und seit zwei, drei Monaten hat er diese Bauchschmerzen.
Bauchschmerzen ist im Periom-Dikalbereich und er beschreibt,
nicht sehr gut ausstrahlen.
Alle Bauch, alle Bauch manchmal hat sie Schmerzen.
Der ganze Bauch, tut Ihnen wirklich?
Ja, der ganze Baum, der ganze Baum tut er weg.
Diese Schmerzen beschreibt der Erdkräftige und einen Überdruck.
Und Schmerzen, das Charakter von Schmerzen ist wellenvoll für mich.
Am Abend, ich habe bemerkt, dass der Patient trinkt viel Alkohol
und bei der Hausarzt ein lieber Problem festgestellt.
Aber der Patient wollte nichts mehr zum Arzt gehen.
Okay, dann geht es ihm jetzt aber schlecht, wenn er hierher kommt.
Ja, deswegen, er ist hier.
Im Vegetativ-Analyse ergab sich, sie hat zugenommen.
Wie viel Kilo weiß er nicht, aber ich glaube, das ist eine Flüssigkeitsansammlung.
Wie nennen wir das? Fachbegriff?
Ja, das heißt Assitz.
Und er hat manchmal Diary, aber das ist, ich glaube, das unaufwähigt.
Er nimmt keine Medikamente, gelegentlich aspirin 50 mg, was war es.
Und in Familienanalyse ergab sich, seine Mutter hat Bluthypertoni und Diabetes Melitis.
Und das ist wichtig für mich, Vater ist, ich glaube, das ist wichtig, Vater hat auch lieber Probleme.
Es kann eine Erkrankheit, genetische Krankheit, aber wir wissen nicht genau, für dich.
Und Vater hat auch Diamant.
Wissen Sie etwas über den Alkoholkonsum des Vaters?
Ja, habe ich das nie gefragt.
Wissen wir nicht.
Ja, das kann ich ja nicht.
Und Vater ist gestorben und seit ungefähr 20 Jahren braucht er täglich 10 Zyginetten und das macht elf Packung pro Jahr.
Haben Sie Zahlen? Zahlen sind ein Problem.
Ich korrigiere das jetzt mal gleich.
30 Zigaretten täglich, ja, 30.
Ja, genau. Er ist nämlich bei 30 Packiers.
Er ist bei 30 Packiers.
Ja, ein Moment.
Nee, er ist sogar bei 60 Packiers.
Seit 20 Jahren auch ein Blick.
Die andere Zeit.
Die 30 Packiers.
30 Packung, ja.
Ich habe hier geschrieben, aber mein Schriftlich ist ein bisschen schlecht.
Ich könnte nicht lesen.
Und er trinkt sehr viel Alkohol.
Ein, zwei, drei Flasche täglich Bier und auch Schnappströmung.
Also hochprothentigen Alkohol.
Ja, schnappte Hochkonsum Alkohol, ja, richtig.
Und ja, das war die Informationen bei den Patienten.
Was ist denn jetzt Ihre Verdachtsiagnose?
Meine Verdachtsiagnose ist eine Neoplasie oder Tümur im Gastrointestinaltrag.
Oder Libazine oder Metastasik, Metastasik Tümur sein.
Vielleicht.
Alkohol ist der Alkohol-Alkohol.
Oder Chronische Pancreatitis, meine Differenzialdiagnose.
Es ist Alkohol, der Alkohol ist der Alkohol.
Oder Libazine.
Was machen Sie denn diagnostisch mit den Patienten?
Wir müssen Körperlühuntersuchung machen.
Worauf achten Sie bei der Körperlühuntersuchung ganz besonders?
Die Farbe von Haut müssen wir beachten.
Die Farbe von Ziklera, die Öl-Analysung,
und jetzt sprechen wir.
Was achten Sie denn von der Optik her?
Der zieht sich aus und Sie gucken den an.
Was sehen Sie?
Ich sehe eine müde Patientin.
Er ist z.B. ein bisschen gelb.
Möglicherweise?
Ja, genau.
Und Syrosa.
Der hat einen dicken Bauch.
Ja, wir haben einen dicken Bauch.
Sie gucken, ob er Bein-Idee-Maschine hat.
Und dann können Sie auch schon mehr u.B. beim Klopfen,
ob der Asthitis hat.
Das bestätigt sich dann gegebenenfalls,
wenn Sie eine Sonografie machen.
Ja, und woher gucken Sie noch bei der Körperlühuntersuchung?
Sie haben verdacht, dass der Mensch viel Alkohol trinkt
und sich damit auch schon geschädigt hat.
Er hat Konzentrationsstörungen beschrieben
und Ruciterigkeit.
Also würde man vielleicht wonach noch bungen?
Ja.
Es fällt mir nichts aus.
Wir machen eine grobe neurologische Untersuchung.
Reflexe.
Und grob neurologische Untersuchungen.
Ob der Darsteller defizit hat.
Also, Plantareritem oder Palmariritem, kann das sein?
Noch mal bitte.
Plantareritem oder Palmariritem, das kann sein?
Keine Ahnung.
Das müssen die aufs Gerissen.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich glaube, das kann sein wegen Gerinnungsprobleme,
weil die Lippen funktionieren nicht gut.
Das kann auch die Patienten höchstmöglicherweise
ein Gerinnungsproblem sein.
Was machen Sie laborteknisch?
Laborteknisch mache ich
neben Funktionen-Teste
ALT, allen Transferas
und
AST
AMILAS,
weil wir in Pankreas beurteilen sollen.
AMILAS und
Gerinnungs-Faktöre
von
Epatubiliare
und
während
das Labor, das Blutuntersuch
machen Sie weiter mit der technischen Untersuchung.
Was gucken Sie da noch?
Technische Untersuchung.
Wir machen Öl, bestimmen Öl-Statüschen.
Auch noch?
Ja.
Wir sollen
Ösephagial-Endoskopie machen, um möglicherweise
zu beurteilen.
Wir sollen einen Zifi machen
für ganz Abdomen beurteilen.
Aber erst mal würde man
als niederspällige Geschichte
ein Ultraschall machen.
Ja, okay,
Ultraschall.
Das würde man ja sicherlich als Erstes machen
und dann warten Sie, was Sie sehen.
Ich habe eine Frage, Frau Berarth.
Wenn es viele Assistenz gibt,
unsere Untersuchung mit Ultraschall
ist ein bisschen nutzlos.
Was meinen Sie da?
Man kann nur feststellen, dass er Assistenz hat.
Es gibt eine große Flüssigkeit
und eine andere.
Deswegen sollen wir
Computer-Termoglaptive-Management machen.
Dann machen wir das hinterher.
Wenn sich das bestätigt,
das ist tatsächlich eine Leberzirose.
Was wäre denn das
Therapie-Management?
Ja,
Sylostherapie ist ein bisschen schwer
und ein langer Prozess.
Und möglicherweise
Organtransplantationen machen.
Das wäre am Ende der Veranstaltung.
Wenn alles andere ausgebremst ist.
Aber diese Patienten haben
schlechte Gewöhnlichkeiten.
Ein viel Alkohol.
Was würden wir ihm denn raten?
Auch wenn wir uns keine Freunde machen.
Er soll weiter trinken
und rauchen.
Er muss unbedingt Alkohol grenzen.
Und rauchen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich richtig gesagt habe.
Wir erzählen im Nikotin-Karenz
aus anderen Gründen.
Aber vor allem Alkoholkarenz.
Dass er seine Leber wieder erholen kann.
Und
Hypotobliaryl-Bioxyzolinbiam machen.
Um Diagnose testzustellen.
Ja, genau.
Das ist noch eine gute Idee.
Dass man ausschließen kann, dass er ein Karzinom hat.
Ja, Karzinom, oder?
Ja, Karinom.
Und ich glaube,
um den Gold-Standard von Diagnose
für Syrosis-Bioxy.
Aber das nach meiner Meinung.
Ich weiß nicht genau.
Ich habe das hier auch stehen.
Dass die Leber-Bioxy-Wegweisen ist.
Genau.
Das war aber im Zusammenhang
mit einem ganz differenzialen Diagnose.
Ich glaube, halten Sie mich auf dem Lausenden.
Was rausgekommen ist, bei Ihren Untersuchungen.
Berichten Sie mir wieder über Herrn Schnüter.
Wenn Sie genauer wissen.
Wichtig ist, ob der Patient pro operativ ist.
Ja, okay.
Gut.
Wie immer logischerweise.
Ich habe das auch schon gesagt.
Die Diagnose war gut, fand ich.
Auch sprachlich ziemlich gut.
Bericht war nicht ganz so gut.
Wobei beim Übergang von einem zum anderen,
da ist mir etwas aufgefallen.
Anagrammatik.
Und zwar, es ist ein Klassiker.
Machen, glaube ich, alle.
Ich habe das auch schon sehr oft gesagt.
Sie sagen, zuerst ich werde Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Ich werde Ihnen Blut abnehmen.
Dann werde ich Ihnen informieren.
Also, ich werde Sie informieren.
Oder zuerst werde ich Sie untersuchen.
Ja, das ist schon sehr gut.
Ich werde Sie informieren.
Und dann werde ich Sie untersuchen.
Das Verb steht im deutschen Satz, an zweiter Stelle.
Wenn er zuerst oder dann vorne wegsteht,
dann kommt, dass ich eine Position nach hinten.
Dann werde ich, was weiß ich,
werde ich Ihnen Blut abnehmen.
Oder dann nehme ich Ihnen Blut ab.
Ja.
Was ganz am Anfang war,
da hat der Patient ja auch nachgehakt.
Auch das habe ich eigentlich schon ganz, ganz oft gesagt.
Machen aber auch viele.
Diese Geschichte.
Zuerst stelle ich ein paar persönliche Fragen.
Persönliche Fragen sind
in unserem Sprachempfinden private Fragen.
Was Sie meinen, sind,
ich stelle Ihnen ein paar Fragen zu Ihnen.
Ich stelle Ihnen ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person.
Wer sind Sie?
Wie heißen Sie? Wann sind Sie geboren?
Wie heißt Ihr Hausarzt?
Wie sind Sie Krankenversicherheit?
Ich fand das sehr urinell, dass Sie danach gefragt haben.
Können wir sagen, allgemeine Fragen?
Eigentlich Fragen zur Person.
Das sind ja, das sind schon Fragen zur Person.
Ja, zu Ihren persönlichen Daten.
Oder man kann auch allgemeine Fragen sagen.
Aber eine persönliche Frage ist das nicht.
Eine persönliche Frage hat Dr.
Gundes mir gestellt.
Er hat nämlich gefragt, haben Sie wechselnde
Sexualpartnerin?
Das ist eine persönliche Frage.
Die war natürlich legitim
aufgrund seiner Situation.
Aber das ist, würde ich als eine persönliche Frage bezeichnen.
Aber ein Arzt darf die natürlich stellen.
Und muss die stellen, genauso wie die Frage nach Drogenkonsum.
Haben Sie auch nicht gefragt?
Haben Sie nicht gefragt?
Ja, ja, ja.
Der Trinktur, so viel Alkohol, da kommt auch die Drogen nicht mehr an.
Ja, ja.
Der Drogen habe ich vergessen.
Ja, ich würde das einfach nicht
persönliche Fragen nennen.
Bei persönlichen Fragen mache ich zu.
Ich will keine persönlichen Fragen beantworten.
Ich kenne sie doch gar nicht.
Fragen zur Person.
Wie heißen Sie?
Adresse, Hausarzt, Gewicht, was auch immer.
Gut.
Was mich gewundert hat,
dass Sie eigentlich nicht so sehr
auf dieses eigentlich ziemlich signifikante
Symptom der Aszitis eingegangen sind.
Er hat gesagt, er hat zugenommen.
Ja, ja.
Und er hat gesagt, seine Hosen passen ihm nicht mehr.
Er hat gesagt, ihr habt gedacht,
ihr habt das abgenommen.
Deswegen, ich habe nicht gefragt.
Er hat zugenommen.
Er hat 5 kg zugenommen.
Vielleicht habe ich es aber auch nicht gesagt.
Das ist ja so ein Leitsymptom, wirklich.
Da hätte man so eine Auffälligkeit.
Ja.
Ich habe das nicht gesagt.
Ich habe eine Auffälligkeit.
Gut.
Ansonsten, wenn irgendwas war,
habe ich eigentlich immer ziemlich gleich interveniert
und habe es gleich korrigiert.
Sonst haben wir, glaube ich, nichts.
Also sagen wir so, die Anamnese war sehr flüssig.
Was Sie sehr schön machen,
dass Sie den Patienten immer mit Namen ansprechen.
Das schafft immer so einen guten Kontakt.
Witzig, Sie haben das gesagt.
Ich weiß immer nicht, wohin guckt die Kamera.
Das Bild.
Ich habe den Augenkontakt verloren, weil ich notiert habe.
Aber das fällt mir als Patient.
Wenn ich den Patienten spiele auf,
wenn jemand die ganze Zeit nur auf sein Ding guckt
oder auf den Computer,
wo seine Fragen stehen,
das ist eigentlich positiv.
Kontakt halten.
Das haben Sie natürlich in der echten Prüfungssituation.
Haben Sie das ja leid.
Da mit dem Kalender.
Das fand ich einen richtig guten Punkt.
Wie gesagt, ich glaube,
Sie sind eigentlich sehr gut zu Hause in der Sprache.
Sie können sich sehr, sehr gut ausdrücken.
Dieser kleine Satzstellungsfehler.
Wie gesagt, der ist super häufig.
Und alle wissen, dass das anders geht.
Aber wenn man zügig formuliert
und wenn man im Gespräch ist,
machen es sehr, sehr viele
nicht Muttersprachler verkehrt.
Ja, das ist ein sehr guter Punkt.
Muttersprachler verkehrt.
Das ist einfach so.
Sie haben noch fünf Wochen Zeit, haben Sie gesagt?
Ja, am 30.
Am 31.